he started out suss Robin but over the
past 80 years the Dick Grayson has
evolved in a way that very few other
comic-book characters have from the way
that he redefines comics and the golden
age to the heroic haircut that he
finally ditched in the 90s here's a
truth behind the evolution of Nightwing
my wings are against earth all the way
back at the dawn of the Golden Age of
comics and the explosion of new
superheroes have hit the page after
Superman debuted in 1938 and became a
ridiculously profitable hit rather than
trying to shoulder into the already
crowded field of costumed superheroes
look up Stardust the super wizard
sometime if you want to see how we had
that side of things was getting Bill
Finger brought artist Bob Kane the idea
of a costumed hero without superpowers
he was a little darker than the others
the character was called Batman you've
probably heard of him the thing is the
Batman who debuted in 1940 wasn't quite
the pop-culture icon that had become
instead the first few Batman stories are
really just ripping off the shadow a
popular pop novel and radio character
but with the pointy ears and about
winged cape instead of a slouch hat on a
trench coat over the next few months
however finger Kane and artist Jerry
Robinson would refine their character if
you need proof that they were just
figuring things out to say Wen's
consider that Batman didn't even have an
origin story until Detective Comics
issue 33 a fall six months after he made
his first appearance it was in Detective
Comics issue 38 however that those
creators added the final ingredient for
making Batman the character we can still
recognize today on a cover that
announced him as a sensational character
find of 1940 which in retrospect this
may be the most accurate a comic book
blurb has ever been Robin was introduced
to the world sidekicks have existed
before Robin but Dick Grayson the circus
acrobat turned a boy vigilante redefined
the role he was wildly popular with kids
in the audience who already loved Batman
and drew excited about having a
character their age who got to hang out
with their favorite character and be his
best friend all things considered it was
a much more pleasant power fun to see
them Batman himself who watched his
parents die in an alley
sure Robyn's parents died too but not
only did he get a new dad his new dad
was Batman no offense for the flying
Grayson's but that's almost always going
to be an upgrade
before long the sidekick population
exploded in the same way that
superheroes had boomed after Superman
Marvel's original Human Torch teamed up
with Toro a few months after Robin
giving readers the dubious
image of a man on fire being accompanied
into battle by a child who was also on
fire by the time Captain America debuted
alongside Bucky Barnes in 1941 a kid
sidekick was virtually mandatory for the
genre but none of them could hold a
candle to Robins popularity while it'd
always be best known as the back half of
Batman and it was clear from the
beginning that Robin was every bit as
popular as his mentor for proof just
look at the comics it's nearly
impossible to find a Batman story in the
40s or 50s when he wasn't hanging out
with the Boy Wonder
but Robin had a plenty of solo stories
even headlining star spangled comics for
five years that means that if you do the
math Robin had more appearances in the
Golden Age than Batman did by the early
80s he was even the star of DC's hottest
book the New Teen Titans a revival of a
series where a bunch of kids sidekicks
were thrown together for wacky
adventures that are being reimagined as
an x-men as superheroes soap opera
finally someone thought to ask the
question that have been hanging over
Grayson's head for at least a couple of
decades by that point if Dick Grayson
can work just as well on his own then
does he need to be Robin the answer it
turns out was no but that also led to
another question what's he going to be
now one of the most interesting things
about Nightwing as a legacy is that it
doesn't actually start with the Batman
at least not in the way that you might
think instead two Dick Grayson inherited
that heroic identity from a son Watts
unexpected place kal-el of Krypton or as
he's known to his co-workers over at the
Daily Planet
Clark Kent
are you a friend oh he's also Superman
but you probably knew that what you
might not know is that he has another
heroic identity too back in 1963
Superman and Jimmy Olsen took a vacation
to the shrunken Kryptonian city since
candor replicated the conditions of
Krypton Superman didn't have any of his
powers while he was there but when he
discovered that he and Jimmy still
needed to fight some battle crime they
created a pair of new identities
inspired by their friends in Gotham City
Nightwing and flame bird in later
versions of the story
Nightwing was a Kryptonian folk hero who
was essentially that world's equivalent
of Batman and dick learned about Sam
when Superman told him the story in both
versions the outcome was the same after
leaving behind the identity of Robin and
paving the way for that role to be
filled by other characters establishing
the idea that Robin was a legacy to be
passed down rather than a static
permanent identity Dick Grayson adopted
the identity of Nightwing as his own
complete with a wild new costume after
he briefly took over for Batman when
Bruce Wayne was recovering from the back
injury it suffered at the hands of pain
Dick Grayson finally took the step that
going forward would define him as a
character he cut the mother to been
rocking since the late 80s seriously
look at this hair it had to go oh and he
also got his own series which would run
for over 150 issues in a lots of ways
the launch of Nightwing was when Dick
Grayson became the standalone character
he'd been on the verge of becoming since
1947 he hadn't been Robin from well over
a decade at that point and there had in
fact been to other Robins in the
intervening years but had always been
seen in the context of other characters
mainly as a member of the Titans now
though things were a little different
dick was still a member of both the
Batman family and the Titans but it was
out to remove that allowed him to
flourish he got his own city to protect
in the form of blood Haven a hilarious
he named eggs above Gotham that had all
the crime but none of the vigilantes and
developed his own roster of enemies he
also got a streamlined minimalist
costume that stands as one of the
greatest designs of the 90s and still
exists with a few minor alterations
today my wing isn't the only other
identity that Dick Grayson adopted after
leaving behind his 40 year career as
Robin in
fact the most surprising thing might be
that he never went back to being Robin
at all instead a dick stepped up after
Bruce Wayne was apparently killed in an
event called final crisis
needless to say Bruce wasn't actually
killed and was instead sent back in time
to caveman days before he clawed his way
back through the timestream while being
pursued by a techno demonic hyper
adapter that was once summoned through a
satanic ritual by Thomas Jefferson
you know comic-book stuff anyway while
all that was going on dick took on the
identity of Batman while Bruce's son
Damian who had been raised by the League
of Assassins became the new Robin dick
and Damian's tenure inverted the classic
dynamic of the duo with Robin being the
violent grump and Batman being more
friendly and approachable
once Bruce returned dick went through
another career change after his identity
was revealed to the world
dick signed up with a multinational
secret intelligence agency called spiral
where he went on sexy adventures that
answered the question of what James Bond
would be like if he lived in the same
universe as say the Riddler eventually
however he found his way back to
blüdhaven and the role of Nightwing just
in time to be shot in the head get
amnesia and emerges rick grayson
presumably because DC comics have
finally hit their breaking point after
80 years of jokes about his name
Walt Dick Grayson has been seen on the
screen since the first Batman film
serial in 1943 DC universes Titans marks
the first time that his identity as
Nightwing has ever been seen in a
live-action project that almost wasn't
the case though you might not remember
it because it was overshadowed by all of
Arnold's extremely cool ice puns
but part of the plot for 1997's Batman
and Robin is built around dick Grayson's
frustration with his role as a sidekick
and his desire to strike out on his own
that makes sense considering that this
particular version of Dick Grayson
appears to have been adopted by Bruce
Wayne in his mid-20s but mostly it's an
excuse for him to be tempted away by
poison ivy in the novelization however
it's mentioned that dick is constantly
switching up his identity and costumes
and an effort to find something new and
at one point he suggests Nightwing as a
potential codename before being shut
down by Bruce that didn't make it into
the film but Robins infamously nippled
costume they're definitely borrows most
of its elements on the Nightwing suit
replacing the previous movies take on
the contemporary 90s Robin costume also
while it wasn't live-action it's worth
noting that Nightwing have been featured
on TV shows before as well
when Batman the Animated Series was
redesigned as a new Batman adventures
Dick Grayson became Nightwing complete
with mullets and the transition from
Robin - Nightwing was even part of the
Young Justice animated series as well my
wing has also been seen occasionally on
Teen Titans go also with the mullet we
just can't get rid of that thing can we
on DC Universe as Titans at dick
Grayson's arc as a character began with
an attempt to move out of Batman's
considerable shadow and past his role as
Robin and in the second season finale he
finally makes a move that he's been
building - for the entire series this
time however he doesn't take his
inspiration from Superman instead the
shifter Nightwing's truly begins when
dick allows himself to be arrested
isolating himself from the rest of the
Titans in an effort to keep the team
away from the danger posed by their
longtime arch-nemesis Deathstroke the
Terminator while he's locked up and
mired in a deep depression he finds a
purpose in helping out a couple of his
cellmates a pair of and documented
immigrants in danger of being deported
and killed once they get home from them
a dick hears about Alice or a legendary
figure from their village you know
Allison in our village Alice who's our
hero he lives between the moon and the
stars and in the time of greatest need
he flies down and saves you realizing
that they're talking about something
that sounds awfully familiar to a lot
ternal Bertina vigilante Victor sais
that this is a new inspiration he needs
to get back in the hero
game escaping from prison and getting a
brand new cape free costume with that
his evolution into Nightwing as complete
burn as longtime fans are no doubt
wondering only time will tell if this
Dick Grayson will ever get the one true
element that separates Robin from
Nightwing a sidekick from the hero that
sweet sweet power mullet
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]